hey guys so there's a glitch that can
actually get torrent to fly it's not
super hard i'm going to show you how to
do it while running on torrent you're
going to dismount and quit out of the
game while you're falling to the ground
so the whole key is to quit out of the
game before torrent completely
disappears when you're dismounting him
when you load back into the game you'll
be standing next to torrent which is
already kind of cool now what you're
essentially doing now is you're going to
stand on a corner of a cliff and you're
going to quit out again you want to
stand as close as you can to a corner of
a cliff because we're basically having
torrent fall to his death once you load
back into the game again you're going to
re-summon torrent twice and the second
time you jump onto torrent you'll be
able to fly around anywhere you want
it's honestly a really fun glitch the
only thing you can't do is jump if you
try to jump you will die but you can get
to some pretty crazy parts of the map by
just flying around on torrent enjoy the
glitch guys